[Music]
morning everybody it's seven o'clock a
new twist in the party gate allegations
from the prime minister's former ally on
today's show the deputy prime minister
dominic raab labour's jonathan ashworth
and the mayor of london sadiq khan it's
tuesday the 18th of january
the prime minister accused of lying to
parliament by his former chief adviser
dominick cummings who says he knew in
advance about a downing street drinks
party during
lockdown island under ash the satellite
images which show tonga before and after
the underwater volcano eruption as a
distress signal is detected
chaos and catastrophe the major u.s
airlines warning a 5g could ground some
aircraft in the next two days
a warning that rising fuel bills could
devastate families with some parents
forced to hide the truth of the cost of
living from their children
we have really really um
struggled
as a household and to hide that from
your children is one of the most
difficult things to do
also on the programme for you this
morning are you on a january fitness
drive but struggling with your stamina
and strength after having covet we'll
talk to the team
researching i should say how long some
symptoms can linger after the virus
he has a document in his possession
[Music]
we'd like you to go to munich tomorrow
and get the document
and we'll speak to the director of the
crown about his new anglo-german
adaptation of a robert harris novel
[Music]
hello everybody another day and another
attack on the prime minister from the
man who used to be one of his closest
allies dominic cummings who was boris
johnson's former chief advisor says he's
prepared to swear under oath that the
prime minister lied to parliament and
knew in advance about a downing street
drinks party during lockdown it's led to
fresh calls for his resignation but
number 10 officials have repeated their
denial that mr johnson was warned in
advance and says he implicitly believed
it was a work event
the prime minister's former chief
advisor wrote in this his blog this i
said to the pm something like martin's
invited to the building to a drinks
party this is what i'm talking about
you've got to grip this madness the pm
waved it aside he went on to say not
only me but other eyewitnesses who
discussed this at the time would swear
under oath that this is what happened
let's bring in our political
correspondent tomorrow cohen should we
oh i'm giving you a full title today
very posh for a tuesday
up some in a minute morning k well the
key question of all this is now shaping
up to be who's telling the truth about
the may 20th 2020 socially distanced
drinks that the prime minister's
right-hand man martin reynolds invited a
hundred people to is it dominic cummings
who claimed yesterday that he personally
said to the prime minister this is a
party you mustn't go ahead with it and
if you don't believe dominic cummings
we've got another source who told sky
news a similar story or is it downing
street who are insisting he knew nothing
about the email he implicitly believed
as the prime minister said himself last
week that this was a work event this is
the key question that sue grey mps hope
is going to give them the answer to but
in the meantime this whole episode is
doing untold damage to the prime
minister's reputation really regardless
of what she ends up ruling what we're
now seeing is tory mps experiencing a
wave of anger from their constituents
and starting to say that whatever she
says it's damaging we saw the health
minister maria caulfield today saying
even if downing street didn't
technically break the rules it's a
breach of the spirit of the rules and
another tory mp desmond swain saying
that if she rules they didn't break the
rules and give him a monopoly get out of
jail free card he says i fear it won't
wash sounds like a death by a thousand
cuts to me we'll put it to dominic rob
the deputy prime minister he'll be with
us in just a few moments time here on
the program so do stay tuned for more on
that also we're going to be speaking to
the shadow work and pension secretary
that's jonathan ashworth of course with
labour criticizing the government for
both downing street parties and the
rising energy bills
i we'll also speak to the london
mercedes khan later in the programme as
he announces a new net zero by 2030
target for the capital
[Music]
and covid rules have eased in scotland
but not for everyone i'll be hearing
from one ice hockey team who've been
left struggling without their fans
images showing the scale of devastation
in tonga following the underwater
volcanic eruption have been taken by
military aircraft a distress call has
been detected as aids try to make it to
the island our south east asia
correspondent siobhan robbins reports
after three days snapshots of a disaster
the first images of the aftermath of
tonga's volcano and tsunami from a
surveillance plane sent by new zealand
saturday's massive eruption sent shock
waves around the world and knocked out
communication
these were tonga's streets before the
volcano erupted
here
afterwards
choked with ash
back in tangatapu on the main island
there there's a blanket of ash two
centimeters uh over everything uh so
they're they're cleaning up uh they're
trying to make sure that everybody has
access to safe water and that the impact
on the food uh
is also uh as little as possible but um
at this point we still have uh a number
of islands that haven't been reached uh
and so the assessment work is ongoing in
the immediate relief the immediate
relief work is ongoing in those islands
tsunami waves of more than a meter
destroyed around 50 homes on the main
island
it's warned walls of water as high as 10
meters hit outlying islands
in some areas damage has been described
as catastrophic
among those confirmed dead is britain
angela glover whose body was recovered
on monday
she's beautiful she was absolutely a ray
of sunshine um that
she would walk into a room and just
lighten the room up and she
loved her life both when she was working
in london and then she achieved her life
stream of going to work in the south
pacific
australia and new zealand are sending
ships with supplies
water is a priority
aid flights will follow once the runways
are cleared of ash
this disaster has irreversibly impacted
lives
access to some of the smaller islands is
still limited
and its warned damage could be
catastrophic
siobhan standing by for us this morning
hello to you uh siobhan and also big
concerns about covid on the island tell
us more about that
good morning k well as i was saying in
the report big concerns firstly about
those low-lying islands which have been
smashed by the tsunami but getting aid
to tonga is now further complicated as
you say by covet concerns that's because
it's one of the few nations which hasn't
had community transmission of covert so
we're being told that even when aid
arrives it's possible that personnel
won't be allowed to physically deliver
it around the island that they'll be
asked to drop it off potentially at the
airport and then that aid itself could
be quarantined because of course the
last thing they want in this disaster
zone is the influx
of possible covert outbreak as well
which would just make the situation even
more difficult
okay and as far as people on outlying
islands are concerned you've made the
point having you that there has been a
distress call
heard and there are
there is help there are ships on the way
but it's going to take two or three days
to get there
yes it's really difficult so tonga is an
island nation more than 170 islands 36
of those are inhabited uh the main focus
for the last few days of course for
pitchers coming out has been on that
main island where we know that 50 houses
have been destroyed but there are these
outlying islands which as you heard from
who there some of them haven't even been
uh reached yet uh the authorities in
tonga said that waves of up to 10 meters
have hit some of those islands we're
getting reports that at least one
village has been totally destroyed what
we don't know though is how that
destruction then translates into
possible deaths
okay siobhan for now thank you
i want to tell you about a challenge
between u.s airlines and the 5g service
ali's here tell us more ali morning so
this is a really stark letter that has
been written to the white house from big
airlines in america big parcel companies
like fedex warning that there could be
chaos if the 5g rollout carries on as
planned because of the interference
basically that the 5g network could have
with planes and
they say i'll quote you a little bit of
this letter because it is really strong
immediate intervention is needed to
avoid significant operational disruption
to air passengers shippers supply chain
and delivery of needed medical supplies
to be blunt it goes on to say the
nation's commerce will grind to a halt
so they say that a significant number of
planes could be stranded um could be
grounded rather that americans could be
stranded abroad it is very stark
language um
and
but i think you know it's worth digging
a little bit into this because airlines
the uh telecom sector rather say that
this has successfully happened in other
countries um they say that um this is
the evidence on this is patchy um when
it comes to the interference that can
come
from the 5g network for planes but
playing company is a warning that
actually things like you know the way
you measure the bottom of the plane
distance to the ground that is really
important in difficult weather
conditions will be really
challenging and that would mean that a
lot of planes will have to be grounded
won't be able to go up particularly in
bad weather conditions this is an
ongoing standoff between the aviation
and telecom sector in the u.s uk as well
well uh it's a problem around the world
i mean some other countries like the
united arab arab emirates have warned um
that it could be a problem as i say that
the evidence is patchy what the aviation
sector in america want is a bit more
time to look at this um but uh the
telecom sectors say that looking in
other countries like in the uk
this has gone ahead and it hasn't been a
problem um but this standoff if it does
go on i think could well have an impact
on people in the coming days unless one
of the two sides backs down okay for now
ali thanks so much indeed thank you
don't forget dominic rob coming up
shortly but first a look at some of
today's other headlines for you and uh
more children are becoming fussy eaters
after getting covered according to
experts it's thought the virus may lead
to some kids suffering from a condition
called
parasmea which distorts smell into
strange and unpleasant smells for those
with the condition chocolate could smell
like petrol oh goodness me and lemon
could smell like rotting cabbage
i'm looking at the latest figures
for covid um almost 84.5 000 new cases
recorded in the uk in the last 24 hours
sadly another 85 deaths taking the
number of deaths within 28 days of a
positive test for kovid19 to 152 075.
northern ireland's first minister says
men need to step up to help prevent
abusive behavior towards women and girls
paul gibbon was speaking at a vigil for
the teacher ashley murphy police are
still hunting for the killer of the 23
year old primary school teacher
a woman who went missing after last
being seen in a windsor nightclub has
been found safe and well police have
said that's good news marnie clayton is
18 and from bracknell and was found in
basingstoke in hampshire a 21 year old
from reading was arrested in beijing
stoke by hampshire police on suspicion
of battery assault occasioning actual
bodily harm breach of police bail false
imprisonment and making threats to kill
the brother of the man who took four
people hostage in texas has told sky
news he was on a call with his children
when he was shot dead misal faisal
akram originally from blackburn was
killed by the fbi inside a synagogue
after a lengthy standoff the synagogue's
rabbi says he threw a chair at his
captor before escaping with his
congregation
we were terrified
and
when i saw an opportunity
um
where he wasn't in a good position
i as made sure that the
two gentlemen who are still with me um
that they were
that they were ready to go uh the exit
wasn't too far away
i told them to go
i threw a chair at the gunman
and i headed for the door
actress and musician hazel o'connor
recovering in hospital after suffering
from a bleed on the brain o'connor rose
to fame in the 80s with hits such as
eighth day and will you let's have a
quick listen
[Music]
the star was found at her home in
southwest france on sunday and rushed to
hospital after what her family described
as a serious medical event
she's now 66 placed in an induced coma
for 24 hours but is now said to be
responding to treatment great news
almost 2 million children in the uk are
living in deep poverty the warning is
from new research from the joseph
rowntree foundation that says adults
could be forced to spend more than half
of their income on rising energy bills
here's katie barnfield
as the cost of living gets higher
anthony worries more and more about his
family
a single dad to two young children
relying on universal credit he already
struggles to afford the basics school
uniforms or even food
we find ourselves in a deficit at this
current state
around about 200 to 400 pounds we have
really really um
struggled
as a household and to hide that from
your children is one of the most
difficult things to do
because of soaring energy prices the
amount companies can charge customers
under a government cap is set to rise in
april by over 50 percent
but new research says the increase could
devastate the poorest families
the joseph rowntree foundation found
after april poorer households will spend
on average 18 of their income after
housing costs on energy bills for single
adult households on low incomes this
rises to 54 percent
a much bigger blow than for
middle-income households who will face a
spend of six percent
they also found nearly two million
children across the country are now
living in what they call very deep
poverty meaning there isn't even money
for the bear essentials
what we need to see is urgent action
from the government to an emergency
payment that goes to families on the
lowest incomes to help them get through
this
crisis
but actually we also need to be asking
ourselves why are families so exposed to
the cost of energy
the government told us they're already
helping vulnerable families through
schemes like the warm home discount but
say they are aware of the pressures
people are facing and will continue to
look at what more might have to be done
katie barnfield sky news
pleased to say the deputy prime minister
is with us now mr rob good morning to
you you've been in your constituency at
the weekend
2743 majority how angry are people
look i think there is some frustration
and people feel it's uh
there's an issue of double standards i
have to say i was out canvassing three
times and i i didn't get it raised a lot
with me what people care about is that
the government is focused on their
issues and making their lives better and
the vaccine roll out with the most
boosted in europe we've got we're the
most tested in europe we've got the most
antivirals in europe in terms of the
vaccine program and as a result we've
come out of lockdown the economy is
growing jobs are up uh wages are up
economic growth is up and it's really
important that we deal with these
allegations and these claims that's what
the sue gray inquiry is for but actually
that allows us to focus on what people
really care about and frankly that's the
overwhelming feedback that i've had and
i think most people across the country
so nobody on the doorstep has brought up
boris johnson's behavior oh it gets
brought up but what do they say well i
think the frustration is is they want to
see the government focusing on their
priorities what do they say about boris
johnson's behavior well you get mixed
views but i have to say it didn't get
raised a lot with me no but when it was
what did they say well i think people
want to know that we're focused they
want to know that there's not double
standards and they want to know that
we're focused on their priorities which
is why uh where we've got to now we're
the most boosted country in europe we're
out of the lockdown measures where the
economy is growing far faster than
almost all of our uh major economic uh
uh comparators and we're talking about
the issues that matter people that's why
i'm talking about crime fighting today
coming down we'll catch i think that's
the issue so they are worried about
double standards then some of your
constituents look i think ever since i
became an mp in 2010 and you remember
the expenses scandal uh i think uh of
course any perception of double
standards is really serious we
understand that frustration that's
precisely why sue gray will look at all
of these issues through great we now be
full transparency and accountability
okay have you spoken about the concerns
of your constituents to the prime
minister
well look i i think he's well aware of
the frustration he expressed that he
articulated it he apologized for it with
contrition in the house of commons
um if it transpires that he lied to
parliament
should he step down okay you're going to
say sue grey i know but the question
remains if a prime minister lies to
parliament should they step down look
i'm not going to speculate on
hypothetical questions speculating i'm
i'm and i'm and i'm confident very
serious that he's definitely promised uh
is straightforward with the house of
commons but of course as you fight you
say sue grey will look at all the
various different bits of snippets and
claims and and assertions okay well
let's just clarify what he actually said
to pmq's or to the house via pmq's last
week
when i went into that garden just after
six on the 20th of may
2020
to thank groups of staff before going
back into my office 25 minutes later to
continue working
i believed implicitly that this was
a work event
dominic cummings says he's lying
well look uh the promise has been very
clear as you heard in the house of
commons uh and uh you know that is the
position and of course sugree will be
able to uh take the name four times
i mean it's a bit of a running joke
about how many times ministers can say
suicide she's the most famous woman in
britain i think if you set up an
investigation to look at something uh
which people are saying and i accept is
as serious as this it's important to
respect the integrity of it so that's
why we refer to and you said that's his
position but this is what dominic
cummings says is the truth i said to the
pm something like martin's invited the
building to a drinks party this is what
i'm talking about you've got to get a
grip on this madhouse
the pm waved it aside he went on to say
not only me but other eyewitnesses who
discussed this at the time would swear
under oath
that this is what happened he says the
prime minister's lying look the pm has
been very clear that's not true or
accurate
and uh
telling the truth so dominic is lying
forgive me if i don't get drawn in to
the soap opera of what uh one or other
claim has been made uh that's not the
position
well no i think it's about whether the
prime minister's lie to the nation and
his colleagues i've been very clear that
i think it's a serious issue which is
why we've got the independent
investigation what i'm not going to do
is preempt by whom get into great yes
indeed well
well done but but we're not i'm not
going to get into commenting on every
little snippet that makes it way into
the papers precisely because as you
asked me i think what people want us
really focused on yes that's important
needs to be looked at proper
transparency the things that matter in
their daily lives which is coming out
this pandemic the economic
measures that we've taken to save 15
million jobs through the course of
pandemic getting ourselves back on the
front foot wages are rising and the
crime fighting agenda which is uh we're
putting forward with doubling the come
back to the magistrates
meantime this is what's happening in
places like derbyshire at constituency
offices they're adorbing lies like that
written all over uh the mp's uh front
door if you will um so the message is
not getting across about what you're
saying well i don't think you can judge
mainstream opinion this country by those
who would act and take a can of spray
paint and or graffiti on someone's
office and i don't think that's
responsible behavior okay what about
maria caulfield then um she's the health
minister she wrote this on her website
it's clear that there was a culture
inside number 10 where even if rules
were not technically broken the spirit
of the rules were and this is completely
unacceptable so if you put aside what
happened in derbyshire this is what the
minister saying well but i think
actually the prime minister's been very
clear that things happen that shouldn't
have done uh he's apologized for that
and sue gray is looking at all of the
details so we can have a proper
accounting of it
yeah okay um
we've also heard from other ministers uh
as well they've underlined uh in more
detail that basically this is death by a
thousand cuts and it's either now or
when sue gray's report comes out
oh sorry what is death by a thousand
cuts and what is now when okay so
i'm glad you asked me i'll go into it in
more detail we've just been hearing um
from what dominic cummings said what
we've seen written on the walls what the
prime minister said at the time um and
in detail what the health minister said
as well all of these things are building
up to saying the prime minister is not
trustworthy
loads of frenetic commentary that's why
you have sue grey looking at this so you
can have a proper investigation into the
facts and then full transparency and the
accountability that comes and if she
finds that the prime minister if she
finds that the prime minister misled
parliament what happens then look i'm
not going to speculate uh on
hypothetical scenarios what i am going
to do is recognize the importance and
the public frustration with any
perception and any reality of double
standards and let sue grey do her job
that's the right thing to do okay um
okay so uh hypothetical is is the other
word that comes up a lot with uh sue
gray i suppose we'll know by the end of
next week and then see what happens then
but you were running the country for two
weeks weren't you when the prime
minister was poorly
were you at all aware
of uh a drinking culture no i mean
the thing i would say is that people
working extremely long hours and so it
doesn't surprise me if they were if
people as you see in other walks of life
had a glass of wine or beer at the end
of a very long week but i'll tell you
against the rules i'll tell you uh not
in a work setting but i'll tell you
something okay because i think it's
important and i can only talk to what i
know and what i see and no one is
credibly i mean there was a speculation
that the
20th of may party was held uh in my
honor to thank me and it was just
ridiculous no of course not ridiculous
it was a party no exactly
no
you refer to it as the tragedy
this is the claim that was made and it
was not what you just said it was
nonsense i wasn't invited and i didn't
attend so what i can tell and so i don't
think anyone is accusing me of that what
i can tell you from what i saw precisely
because i did spend sustained period is
is 10 particularly during that period uh
when the pm was unwell uh and uh in
hospital but also throughout the
pandemic has been working phenomenally
hard under grueling conditions and i and
i do not and i do not and i do not
personally from my own experience
recognize the caricature that they were
all uh partying uh that this was
incredibly serious uh and difficult and
dedicated uh team so i'm just gonna dj
in the basement they they've got on will
swing and broke it they took a suitcase
okay i'm just telling you what i saw and
why my experience yeah but you can't say
that they weren't taking advantage a lot
of the people in downing street given
that you know we've had several
eyewitnesses who illustrated what
happened okay what i'm telling you is
what i saw you asked me for my personal
experience and what i'm telling you is i
think that uh um the the the conditions
in a crucible-like context in a pandemic
that we've the likes of which we've
never seen before
all of my exposure direct and personal
was to an incredibly hard working team
but the pictures that we've seen look i
i feel as frustrated as anyone else um i
think double standards is toxic um i i
get all of that i get the frustration
majesty feels about what was happening
in dining street the day before number
10 is number 10 is apology but i wonder
what you think look i think it was right
to apologize for it of course i want to
see comply i'm a lawyer by heart i want
to see the rules uh comply with i also
recognize that
as lawmakers the government has got to
be
take a lead show um it is uh acting to
the highest standards otherwise how can
we expect others to follow i get all of
it yeah but if i may a deputy prime
minister you're picking and choosing
about what you believe and what you
don't believe you know some some parties
did go ahead the day before the uh the
funeral of the duke of edinburgh but the
one on the 20th of may wasn't a party no
the question we have to wait for the
questions
yes but but you were asking me what i'd
seen you in fact perfectly fair you say
i spent a lot of time in number ten
during the period where the pm was
unwell and uh and after um in my
capacity's first secretary and uh and
since and fine sex at the time and all
i'm telling you is you've never seen
this fridge that they're talking about
no i don't i was never saw the fridge i
mean
and all i'm saying is in fairness i
think there's something of a caricature
that is being depicted uh against the
incredibly professional dedicated hard
work that i saw and i can only vouch uk
good uh conscience about what i saw
sounds like they're all gonna be thrown
under the bus we'll have to wait and see
what happens um with that whether it's
got 350 million quid written on the side
of it or not yes we will apparently uh
tell me about the courts look we've got
this backlog in the crown courts in
particular we've started to get the
backlog down in the magistrates court
since the peak in june we've got the
crown court backlog which he is the most
serious cases and was affected by the
socially dis the social distancing rules
particularly jury trials that backlog is
down by 2000 we put secured a billion
pounds to get the courts back up and
running over the next three years and
get the the backlog down one of the
additional things we're doing is
doubling the sentencing powers of
magistrates from six months to 12 months
and what that will do is get more cases
um going through the courts we will see
uh criminals brought to report to book
victims having to wait less time and a
further estimated 1700
of those cases in the backlogged crown
courts reduced so this is i think the
right thing to do and i hope everyone
will support it well except the criminal
bar association who says negligible
impact
well it will have an impact uh on top of
the 2000 that we've reduced the backlog
so the backlog in june at the peak was
around 61 000 it's now down to 59 000.
this will take 1 700 off but i'll tell
you what um we need to work together as
a team the lawyers are incredibly
important they've done a great job
through the pandemic the judiciary and
the court service have but i have to say
the criminal bar association have been
threatening strike action the one thing
that will hold back our recovery from
this pandemic will be an irresponsible i
think uh
unwarranted uh industrial action uh by
criminal barristers we are out of time
but indulge me if you would with your
expertise when you were foreign
secretary we're being told that we're
days away in ukraine days away from what
i don't know i'm not sure what you're
well i'm referring to the fact that the
ukraine and russia the russian more than
100 thousand troops are on the russian
border we're being told
away
i had uh the ukrainian ambassador sat
there just last week and he was
concerned about world war three and
sending people back in body bags well
we're absolutely clear ukraine uh along
with our partners and allies we support
ukraine's territorial integrity its
rights to defend itself and we've been
very clear to moscow
that any invasion will be met with
sanctions and economic and financial
response by the international community
and it's important uh that russia
de-escalates and dials down its rhetoric
and its aggressive behavior
uh you're always honest and open thank
you very much for joining us it's gonna
be an interesting week next week isn't
it who is this there's a report
apparently coming out i can't remember
the name yeah exactly it's good to talk
to you as always thank you deputy prime
minister looking at the front pages for
you the metro quotes from the dominic
cummings report who says he and the
other downing street staff would be
prepared to swear under oath that boris
johnson lied to parliament about parties
held at number 10 during lockdown
it's also a big story for the times
newspaper this morning
and for the mirror as well there you go
what about the guardian
yep they're saying exactly the same
thing
still to come on the program for you
we're going to be speaking to the former
politician tom watson about his
appointment as chair of the laboratory
and testing industry organization what
does that do stay tuned and find out
[Music]
hi everybody our top stories for you so
far this morning on the breakfast
program and sky the prime minister's
former top adviser dominick cummings
says that boris johnson knew about the
downing street party and lied to
parliament
the satellite images which showed tonga
before and after the underwater volcano
eruption as a distress signal is
detected
and a warning from us airline chiefs
against introducing new 5g technology
onto aircrafts for fear of rendering
them unusable
[Music]
laboratory and testing industry
organization has appointed former
politician tom watson as its chair in an
effort to better relations between the
government and testing organizations it
comes as more people turn to covid
testing companies amid the growing
threat of the omicron variant let's talk
to tom now should we um hi tom thanks
for joining us on the program this
morning how do you see your brief
good morning good to be with you again
um well this is about industry leaders
trying to talk to government about what
the future looks like to make sure that
standards are maintained that consumers
are supported
and that there are no surprises in
policy
um okay but are we not in a position
where we are relying less and less now
on these tests given what we've been
hearing from dining street and by the
26th of january we might not need them
in place at all
yeah we've seen some of the restrictions
been
removed and we support that uh that
general thrust
what we say though is that testing is
actually the antidote to lockdowns if
you're coming out of a lockdown or
you're reducing restrictions people need
to know
the process of the variant so a mix of
lateral floats tests and pcr tests is
vital if we're going to open the economy
up again
why has this not happened before now
well it hasn't it
it has in previous lockdowns but and
we're particularly concerned about the
the thing at the airports because uk
borders are the kind of that's where you
you don't just stop migrants and
um and pirates you also stop viruses at
airports and the pcr test is the way
that you can get the early spotting of
new variants
and the government themselves have said
that it's inevitable there's going to be
a new variant we don't know how virulent
or dangerous it's going to be but the
pcr test is the unit that you actually
find you start to find this the material
to shut to get you that early warning
and actually with omnichrome we we
realized quite early on that the virus
had
entered the country as a result of those
pcr tests
yeah it's been pretty haphazard though
hasn't it that testing up until now
well the inter that's why this the ltio
is a new standards body it came together
towards the end of last year and and it
was some of the established um
organizations in in the lab testing
industry that wanted to make sure that
consumers were protected because sadly
unfortunately with with all things like
this there are some road players that
enter markets when there's growth
and that's really why we've established
ourselves and of course when the
government changes decisions very very
quickly
it's hard for those laboratories to
adapt very very quickly so what we're
hoping for and have got actually is a
good working relationship with all
parties in westminster and particularly
those key departments that are dealing
with the covid crisis
taught me talk to me about what life was
like in downing street you were an
integral player for a very long time in
number 10 and number 11. um what's it
like once you get into that rabbit
warren if people were having events
parties in the garden or in the basement
or breaking the child swing or there was
a big booze fridge would you know about
it if you were a politician
there was never i was there with gordon
brown so things were a little bit more
austere than uh different leaders i mean
i what i will say is it they work very
intensely in number 10 they work very
very long hours so it wasn't unusual to
be eating your breakfast lunch and
dinner at your desk if there was a
crisis on or some you know which there
usually is when you're in number 10
um
and and so
and and you and if there were receptions
in that in the number 10 garden you
probably wouldn't know what they were
about because they were always visiting
dignitaries and ambassadors and
you know members of the public coming in
for events um
so
it was not under lockdown though eh
i don't remember there ever been a dj
rig there in my time okay but i do
remember working very closely with sue
gray who who then was the i was the
civil service minister and she was the
director of an
organization ethics which was very
soviet sounding and her job at the time
or one of her jobs at the time was to
review all the memoirs that
ex-politicians had written
and i remember reading her ever to read
john she never told us what was in the
books but she i remember having to read
john prescott's memoir
to see whether he revealed any state
secrets and she said to him you didn't
do that john but you did swear a lot do
you have to be so rude in every chapter
and i think he took all the words out of
his memoir so i mean to go to john
prescott to tell him to rewrite a book
he's just said to a publisher she's
pretty tough
yeah but a lot of your former labor
colleagues are saying that she's not
independent because she works for the
prime minister do you think that's
that's fair
i think it's very unfair to allow a
civil servant to judge a
powerful prime minister although of
course when they set this process up i
don't think they quite realize that the
prime minister would be under so much
scrutiny
knowing sue grey as i do though i think
she will i think she will establish the
facts the facts will speak for
themselves i don't i think she's pretty
fearless in all of that
um but you know i but and i have to say
this is one internal danny street report
that i will actually read this time
um now what about this photograph of you
with christine lee an alleged spy in
2016 what was all that about did you
take any money off her
i literally have no idea
who she is
where i met her or what that event is
i'm afraid okay i i've definitely not
taken any money over and i don't know i
i don't i don't even know the event that
that's at the thing about when you're at
these receptions people come up to you
and have photographs all the time
um so it was a shock to me when i read
it in the daily mail this weekend
okay he's certainly lost a lot of weight
since then barry gardner apparently took
one of your former colleagues took 600
grand offer should he give it back
he's probably spent it by now if i i
think the report said he was spending it
on research so i suspect he can't do
that but i i
i don't know whether i think barry said
he was liaising with the intelligence
service as well
i think that's probably a good thing to
do if they think that she's a chinese
spy
appropriate to take six hundred thousand
pounds off somebody and not really ask
too many questions it seems a lot of
money
well you have to sort of you you form
your own view there don't you you have
to make your own judgment what's your
view that's what i'm asking
well
if
if a chinese
if someone had approached me at a
reception and offered me 400 000 pounds
i'd probably want to find out what their
background is
or it might be that he was misled of
course
it may well be an awful lot of money uh
past uh hands before he found that out
some might say allegedly just for the
benefit of the lawyers just before i let
you go if you were offering sue gray any
advice today what would it be
stay strong sue grey and do but be
honest uh in your report i have
absolutely no doubt she'll do that
good to talk to you as always thanks
very much indeed for joining us tom
thanks okay
thank you
the name sue gray has been mentioned
once or twice that's the person leading
the investigation uh into what happened
in downing street but who exactly is she
had a bit of an insight there from tom
let's um have a look in more detail
she's a senior civil servant she spent
much of her career working in the public
service currently in the department for
leveling up
that means that she's working with
michael gove in the 1980s she took a
career break from the civil service to
run a pub in newry in northern ireland
it's reported that during this time she
confronted ira paramilitaries who were
attempting to steal her car
she returned to the civil service and
had risen through the ranks taking
senior cabinet office roles including
head of the propriety and ethics
committee or
the actual
organization we were hearing a bit more
about that as well weren't we from tom
watson and a stint as the permanent
secretary of the department of finance
northern ireland executive
um
so she has been involved in a number of
high profile investigations including
four into former cabinet ministers dr
liam fox andrew mitchell and theresa
may's then deputy de facto prime
minister
damian greene
but perhaps none as high profile as
partygate where she has national
scrutiny and as investigating her bosses
when she reports her findings
they will go to the pm land on his desk
that's the very same person who has been
accused of the wrongdoing what happens
after that
that's what we keep trying to get to the
bottom of
northern politicians want to tell us
meantime scotland has relaxed its rules
for dealing with the pandemic large
outdoor public events can now take place
without social distancing or capacity
limits but restrictions on indoor events
remain in place here's james matthews
all right we got charlie
conker
game night for the dundee stars
this match against manchester storm
would have drawn 2 000 spectators
covered restrictions on indoor events
capped the crowd at 200.
when you've only got 200 possibly less
than 200 it's so difficult to try and
get the guys going and get everybody
into the game still
a sport like this which is underfunded
and not as popular we need fans
quite annoying but
first time ever
[Applause]
[Music]
this was early in the morning of match
day team preparations have to be
shoehorned in between other athletes
needing access to the ice and public
skating sessions
covered restrictions have cost the
dundee stars more than a hundred
thousand pounds and counting
well it's just an extra week well that's
two home games you know what i mean
that's an extra two home games that's
going to be a total of six games now we
will be playing with restrictions well
that's you know almost 20 of our season
in a uk league with different crowd
limits depending who you play there's a
home disadvantage in being a scottish
team
yeah
i'm not winning
we started to find our game so hopefully
now let's find it on saturday all right
boys having found their game today
dundee are looking for their crowd back
james matthews sky news dundee
in other news a drone attack targeting a
key oil facility in abu dhabi
has claimed the lives of three people
and sparked a fire at abu dhabi's
international airport the attack which
involved five ballistic missiles and
several drones has been claimed by
yemeni's houthi movement the group
warned it could target more facilities
in the united arab emirates let's find
out more should we ali standing by for
us now um tell us a bit more about the
background to this ali if you would
please good morning
yeah morning k so this happened about 24
hours ago
in abu dhabi an explosion a number of
explosions just outside the
international airport we don't know
whether the airport was the intended
target and the drones missed
or whether they did hit their target and
if they did then we don't know the
significance yet
of what they hit because the uae hasn't
given more details on that the
consequence though uh really twofold
firstly the number of casualties six
wounded but three lost their lives two
of them indian one of them pakistani and
the second consequence really is that
the uae has been targeted again by the
houthis but this time you know
reasonably close to built up urban areas
of abu dhabi a city that many people
watching will know well either because
they've been on holiday to the uae or
they've been there for work
or for business why has this happened
well the uae has historically been
involved in the conflict in yemen
on the government side along with the
saudis against the iranian-backed
houthis having said that the uae in 2019
tried to extract itself on that ongoing
very messy conflict and has largely done
so
barring a few elements still there to
help uh defend key cities the houthis
say they carried out the attack to force
yemen to force a uae entirely uh out of
yemen so in response overnight the uae
has carried out airstrikes in the yemeni
capital sana killing at least 14 people
and so
the uae despite trying to get out of
yemen is finding itself dragged back in
to that very very messy conflict and the
houthis are demonstrating how they can
if they want to target key cities like
abu dhabi
okay ali thank you
looking at some of the stories that have
caught our eye today wadi in charge of
the pictures in the morning papers this
is what we found the telegraph has a
picture of a horse and rider plunging
through a bonfire during a religious
festival in spain honoring the patron
saint of animals very friendly to me
now the guardian has this picture of
david attenborough reporting that some
big budget shows could be threatened by
the licensed fee freeze
the mirror shows us pictures of care
home residents who have recreated some
classic works of art using old clothes
how cool is that maybe we'll try and get
some of them
on the program and size doesn't matter
the sun has some pictures that ask cats
versus dogs who is the real
alpha i think we know the answer and
finally the express has some spectacular
shots of the wolf moon looming over some
of england's landmarks there you go
gorgeous
now the minimum self-isolation period
for people testing positive for covid19
in england has been cut to five full
days the quarantine period has been
reduced after a review of the medical
evidence to help ease shortages across
the economy but what sort of impact will
it have
well let's talk about it in more detail
professor monica gandhi from san
francisco is with us hello to professor
thanks for staying up late to talk to us
on the program you did this recently in
the u.s didn't you what impact did it
have
you know it didn't change anything to
reduce the isolation period so why did
the cdc do this and now you're doing
that here in the uk
three reasons one is that
there was the largest contact tracing
study showed us from taiwan this was
published in jama internal medicine in
november 2020
that
most transmission occurs within the
first five days of developing symptoms
to be fair actually all of the
transmission occurred in this contact
tracing study in the first five days so
no transmission after six days you can
look at viral load all you want the
contact tracing studies really are the
best way to see when transmission is
occurring second reason is that after
vaccination
what happens is that your your immune
system comes in starts trying to kill
that virus and it's much less infectious
even if it's turning up on a rapid test
and so there was a recent study in the
american society of microbiology that
shows that just because you have a rapid
antigen test positive lying that does
not translate to infectiousness
but what we did see um during the early
days of covid was that people contracted
kovid they looked as though they were
getting better and i remember my gp
specifically saying to me it was between
days eight and ten if you were going to
be pulley that was when you were going
to take a proper nose dive does that is
that still the case
so what's changed is immunity versus
non-immunity so remember at the
beginning of the pandemic when people
got coveted they would have a high viral
load and they would actually culture the
virus
exec
consecutively and it was still
culturable and likely infectious out to
10 days that's why the isolation period
was 10 days what's changed now in the
pandemic well number one most of the
people who are isolating are vaccinated
and so that really does change the
equation there was a study out of italy
among health care workers who got
breakthrough infections with delta they
were positive on one day they had no
symptoms and they were negative the next
day so we have to change things with the
updated science after vaccination
so is there an argument for not
isolating at all
so where will we go when the endemic
phase because right now we're all in a
transition you in the uk us in the u.s
europe is doing things also differently
we're transitioning from pandemic to
endemic when we get to the endemic stage
we will treat it like influenza we will
treat it that you should stay home when
you're sick but you don't have to test
out to go back home and we will not do
any asymptomatic testing anymore we're
not there yet but that's where we'll get
to after the omicron surge and you don't
quarantine just because you've been
exposed think about all the other
viruses we'll start treating it like
other respiratory pathogens but right
now in the intermediate stage and
omicron's causing a lot of disruptions
in healthcare worker settings in the
economy and that's why this decision was
made by the cdc to be practical and also
to go along with the data and i think
you're doing the right thing in the uk
fascinating stuff good to talk to you
thank you
thank you thank you
quick look as what
i'll say that again quick look at what's
happening as far as the weather is
concerned this morning
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
southern britain mostly settled over the
next few days overnight fog and frost
but there'll be some rain in the north
and the west
it's a frosty start for many dense
freezing fog bringing a risk of travel
disruption to central and eastern parts
of england and wales in particular
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
now they say that blood is thicker than
water but that doesn't seem to ring true
when you see these guys a three-legged
lion
two twin tigers and a labrador were
filmed playing together with a ball at a
siberian zoo
i mean first question why is it only got
three legs fortis the lion cub
tragically had to have one leg amputated
there you go after a birthing injury
prompting the zoo to bring in elsa the
labrador to keep him company as he
recovered
lavender and her sister lyanna arrived
later as a present from vladivostok the
animals have been best friends ever
since
those are cool pictures aren't we um
coming up in the next hour gonna be
talking to tamara in more detail about
what the deputy prime minister has had
to say today he was been on the program
within the last 45 minutes surprise
surprise he talked about sue gray and
not wanting to talk about hypothetical
situations
until we get her results from her
extensive review that is due by the end
of next week so we're going to get more
on that we also put that to a former
very senior politician as far as labour
was concerned that's tom watson he used
to work in downing street and he knew he
knows sue gray personally he said that
she was a formidable uh civil servant
but it was totally unfair that she found
herself in a position where she is
having to pass judgment on basically a
man who is her boss none other than the
prime minister
we have heard from the government they
are trying to move away from what's been
happening at downey street instead
underlining in a lot more detail about
what they are planning to do not only
with the courts to try to get rid of
that log jam but also in the channel and
what's going to happen allegedly with
some border force vessels that are
pushing and pushing um
refugees let's call them refugees back
who are trying to get to the uk by using
sonic noises from megaphones is that
even human anyway
that is one of the things that is being
speculated on should be done in other
words
the government is doing its level best
to try to distract us from what's been
happening at number 10 downing street i
wonder what labour thinks about all of
that john ashworth
um will be joining us in the next few
moments to give us his take of course
labour not without guilt we've seen the
leader of the labour party who had a
beer and a body a photograph taken of
him indoors when it was against the
rules to do so on what they've got to
say about that stay tuned for more
[Music]